LOKESH KRIS: Welcome to the
"Data Modernization McKesson
Story."
My name is Lokesh Kris.
I'm a data management
and data analytics
specialist at Google Cloud.
I have several
years of experience
working on large public and
private cloud deployments
and migrations.
I also had the
opportunity to start
a couple of companies
in the past,
just advertising and
other technologies.
I'm a spiritualist,
dad, traveler.
I love reading books and
enjoy cooking when I'm free.
The agenda for today
is to understand
how large enterprises
approach data modernization
and solve some of their
complex challenges,
such as data modernization,
reducing the cost, improving
agility for business and
integration, et cetera,
and move their business
forward progressively.
McKesson is a large
customer I work with,
and we are going to
be hearing from them
and how they are successfully
executing their data
modernization strategy
on Google Cloud.
Why do enterprise
modernize today?
Why are they looking
at modernization?
They increasingly want to
address the latest business
opportunities.
And they also want to
leverage the latest technology
trends and architectures,
and the latest technologies
available in the cloud.
And they do so by adopting
or migrating to the cloud
and making cloud as
part of the journey.
And enterprises are
increasingly looking
to modernize the
business application
by moving to the cloud.
And why Google Cloud?
What makes Google
Cloud different?
We deliver end to end security
solutions from the data center
all the way to the end user with
a purpose-built infrastructure
and security by default. We
believe in an open cloud,
and we have designed
Google Cloud to support
whatever system best
suits your needs,
whether hybrid or multi-cloud,
or something in between.
We strive to make Google
Cloud easy to use, automating
manual tasks and configuration
wherever possible so your teams
can focus on deployment
and development and less
on managing infrastructure.
We embed intelligence
in everything,
making it easy for
you to apply AI and ML
in your own organization.
Lastly, we bring you the best
of Google in our solutions,
and we can help
you create a more
innovative and
collaborative culture
in your own organization.
And with that, I
have great pleasure
in introducing Anshul Kumar,
Director of Data Analytics
and Innovation for McKesson.
ANSHUL KUMAR: Thank you,
Lokesh, for having me.
I'm excited to
share my experiences
so far, and the amount of work
that Lokesh and the product
teams have helped us get
through, it's pretty cool.
My team focuses on the analytics
that powers our B2B customer
experiences.
What that means is, all
the analytics that's been
in our e-commerce platforms.
Our value prop to
our customers is
we will give them access, in
addition to the health care
products, the right
products at the right cost,
we'll also give them access
to analytics, which will help
them run a more optimized shop.
And that's the piece
that our team works on.
When I'm not working, I am
exploring other open source
technology stacks.
I'm a dad and an
aspiring blogger.
We have a quick "One
Minute at McKesson" video.
Hope you enjoy it.
NARRATOR: It's 11:15
AM on a Tuesday.
In the next minute, McKesson
will make better health
possible for millions of
people at the same time.
A young girl in Los Angeles
will start her road to recovery
after her primary
care physician used
a rapid strep test we delivered
to make the right diagnosis.
An aging Tucson woman will move
into an affordable long term
care facility that uses our
inventory solutions to control
costs and improve patient care.
A woman in Paris receives
personalized treatment
for her skin condition
from our local pharmacist,
avoiding a trip to
the dermatologist.
A line of third
graders in Little Rock
will head to the nurse's
office for needed flu shots
we supplied to their
local school district.
A pharmacist in Montreal
reminds a diabetes patient
to take his medication
because the system we
developed with manufacturers
triggered an adherence
consultation.
A single mom in a rural area
gets her critical medication
and stays on budget because
we supply her local pharmacy
with a cost effective generic.
This is the difference
McKesson makes in one minute.
we make every minute.
What will we make possible in
the next minute, the next hour,
the next year?
It's now 11:16 AM.
It's time to get back to work.
ANSHUL KUMAR: That was
"One Minute at McKesson."
We are in the health care
distribution business.
McKesson has a rich
history of selling
many different
products, and some
of the brands that we
see here on the slide
were, at some point,
owned by McKesson.
Founded in 1833, it's
a Fortune 7 company.
80,000 strong.
Headquarters in Irving, Texas.
We do have a global footprint.
We have our business units
in the European Union
and in Canada.
And especially
during the COVID-19,
I'm very proud to be
part of Team McKesson.
Our CEO and device
project [INAUDIBLE]
at the White House, and
the McKesson distribution
leadership team.
and honored these
leaders and the folks.
And special shout out
to them for helping
out getting the product and
the hot spots [INAUDIBLE]..
In this talk, we'll start
with the current state,
how we got here.
We'll get into McKesson's
way of adopting cloud.
And it's a blend of org
structure, processes,
training resources.
We'll touch upon
foundational things
to have in place before you
start your cloud journey,
or while you have
your cloud journey.
We'll talk about
various patterns
when you think about data
storage, and end of the call,
where are we on this journey.
LOKESH KRIS: So, Anshul, what
led you to choose Google Cloud
platform?
Could you please walk us
through some of the drivers
as why Google Cloud platform?
ANSHUL KUMAR: That is a
good question, Lokesh.
Folks will have another
big long list, I'm sure.
But personally, for
me, the health care
APIs that Google Cloud
platform offers out of the box.
Those can be a game changer.
Our customers are physicians
office, surgery centers,
and hospitals.
So if we could leverage these
APIs to latch onto their ERP
systems and do the point in
time delivery of the product
when they need it, that's
going to be fantastic.
We talked about the
rich McKesson history,
and it should be no surprise
that over time there
were multiple mergers and
acquisitions that took place.
And when you go through
mergers and acquisitions,
you also bring in teams
from different companies
with IT teams.
They bring in their
own technology stacks.
So it should be no surprise to
see multiple ERP systems here,
multiple [INAUDIBLE],, and
multiple application databases.
When I talk about multiple
application databases, not just
the name of the database,
but also the flavor.
If we have [INAUDIBLE],,
we have SAP.
We have Oracle.
We have SQL.
We have MySQL, and so on.
In addition, we also have
multiple [INAUDIBLE] tools
and various ways to
replicate information.
This is a good opportunity
for standardization.
That should be the takeaway.
And we are multi-cloud shop.
McKesson has access to
Microsoft Azure, Public Cloud,
and Google Cloud, and for
our CRM, we are Salesforce.
So we talked about,
earlier on, multiple teams
getting together, so
thousands of people.
Just giving them keys
to the Public Cloud
is not going to be the most
effective way for cloud
adoption.
And the senior leadership
did identify this,
and they decided to adopt SAFe.
What is SAFe?
SAFe is Scale Agile Framework.
So this was agile
for enterprises,
larger enterprises.
And there's tons
of good information
out there on the internet.
You can search upon it.
Real quickly, the different
milestones or phases
that I've highlighted here.
Project was a senior leadership
buy-in for the process.
Yes, SAFe is what we
are going to adopt.
Foundation is setting up of the
internal McKesson cloud team.
The internal McKesson
cloud team is
responsible for the
connectivity to GCP
public cloud, all the cost
related conversations, all
the security related
conversations, new feature
enablement, giving access
to our development team
such as myself, they do it all.
And the third phase
was migration.
So migration could
mean different things
to various people.
Specifically for my group,
we had some applications
which were running
at capacity, and we
thought these are good
candidates to be moved over
to public cloud from on prem.
So that's what we did.
We ended up migrating
those applications,
small, manageable
sizes, and the goal
is after 100% on
public cloud, we just
start building native
cloud applications,
reduce our technical debt,
and app modernization.
Just keep our eyes open
for any opportunities
for modernization.
As part of the
McKesson GCP adoption,
the McKesson team got
access to a few free
on demand learning programs.
These were instrumental
for my team,
and they pretty much
acted like a slingshot.
Folks could go in
and at the self pace,
at their own leisure, learn
the new technology stack.
And next thing you know,
they're building upon that.
So I highly recommend
checking this feature out
with your Google account.
Executives.
It's not just for the
hands on developers.
There is some good
content out there
for leadership folks as well,
for transformation and just
cloud adoption.
This one, I would call
it a replication strategy
as a foundational piece
and for going to cloud.
And why I'm calling
it foundational
is we decided to go with a
less complicated workflow
in the public cloud first and
not rule out our ERP day one.
ERP systems are the ones which
are running our core business
of big package shipping.
So we do not want to go with
ERP day one into public cloud.
Instead, we went with
analytical workloads
and the application, the
e-commerce workloads,
into public cloud.
And when you do that
with the original data,
it's going to initiate
on your ERP systems.
So how do you
compute on the cloud?
You cannot compute on the cloud
unless you get that enabled
source information.
And this is what the
context is for this slide.
It's good to at
least think through,
how do you get your
ERP information,
the orders which are getting
generated day in, day
out, how do you make them
available through one
single, structured
flow into cloud?
And from there, the
app development teams,
which are many, can
utilize the source data
and run with the
apps that they are
closest to in their own
subject matter expertise.
And our VP would say--
he would often use the
phrase "10-yard teams"
who know how to run 10 yards,
but they would not know how
to score a touchdown.
You don't want to be in that
situation, where multiple app
development teams are just
using their own method,
opening up firewalls between
your on prem data centers
and onto your public cloud.
And all of them
are more than often
replicating the
same information,
which can result into
very different problems,
like first is reduced
visibility for sure.
You do not know what's
being moved from on prem
to the cloud.
And then the other one
would be the security team
has limited
visibility into what--
is there patient information
that's flowing through?
And if yes, what are
the controls in place?
This one is a real graph
database screenshot
of just replications running
within the Oracle databases.
This is DB Link.
It does not cover the
other replications
that we are using outside
of that Oracle cluster.
This is just [INAUDIBLE]
Oracle cluster.
The good thing here is
this is all constraint,
and it's on prem.
But imagine if this was
the case for connectivity
from on prem to
the public cloud.
You do not want that to happen.
It should be nice, and
it should be measurable.
It should be manageable.
So replication, I
cannot emphasize enough.
It's definitely worth a pause
for the solution architects,
the enterprise architects,
and rethink it,
and try to get a grasp around,
no more uncontrolled port
holes to the cloud.
If there is an outage,
if the network is
running into contention,
what kind of insights
do you have on this?
Is there a way to measure
who's running that workload?
Manageable outages.
How do you manage outages?
How to think about and keep
a close eye on the network
bandwidth.
If app development team
A is using sales history,
or if they are moving sale
history to the public cloud,
unless you have a good
replication strategy,
the team B and C will never
know that the same information
that they are looking
for, it's already
on the public cloud,
versus them again
pulling the same information
through the wire.
And again, when you think
about the replication tool,
think about a good [INAUDIBLE]
solution on the cloud
and use that.
You can pretty much
start creating that,
build on that story.
From there, you can think about
the different heterogeneous
RDBMS solutions.
Perhaps also land those
events into Kafka Queue,
build APIs through it and so on.
In our case, we do have,
our application databases
are running on Oracle DB, and I
talked about the rich McKesson
history.
So for this specific version of
the one we have on the slide,
it's almost around 20 years
old, and more than often,
the implementation
reflects upon the skill
set that were on the team
at that point in time.
So the specific
application database
is running low latency calls
as app databases should,
but non-business
[INAUDIBLE],, it's also
extended to be doing
batch processing,
because that team
had Oracle talent.
So they ended up doing ETL
batch work non business hours,
and this is not uncommon.
So when we were thinking about
what's the ideal PaaS solution
to move away from
Oracle, because we
are running capacity, we
found the ideal candidate
to be MySQL.
But again, we went
with PostGreSQL
for reasons I'll talk about
in the few next slides.
But good information
out there for folks
who are in the same boat,
multiple conversion utilities
available, like
migVISOR or Ora2pg.
You also have GCP heterogeneous
tools product team.
You can interview them and
see if they can do something
to ease that migration for you.
So MySQL, I talked about, is
ideal candidate for app DBs.
It is thread based,
and it's better
for low latency connections.
And it can support
many connections,
and that's what we see
happening with Oracle databases.
And at the same time, you have
for a lot more success stories
of folks having moved
from Oracle to PostGreS.
So that's one of the--
this aspect of the many
success stories, this
weighed in heavily
for our decision.
The other specific-- the
utilization of sequences, we
[INAUDIBLE] sequences on Oracle,
we used of triggers heavily,
which are also
supported on PostGreSQL.
And we are heavy into
materialized views.
Do not judge.
This is just how it exists,
just in the center here.
And we do use
Oracle partitioning.
Our success criteria was
also, we do not have--
get it done with what do
you have, so more with less.
The goal was to make minimal
changes to the Java app
code and minimum changes to the
current legacy application--
I would call legacy now--
and still move away from Oracle.
Given those guardrails,
PostGreS is our best candidate
that we ended up picking.
Been happy in an Elastic
shop for almost five years,
we started on prem.
We were running
capacity, so we ended up
moving our Elastic cache
databases to Azure.
Azure, at the time, did not
have PaaS service, which
could support aggregate
functions, which we heavily
utilize, "group bys" and so on.
So we had to fall back
into the IES setup.
Now, IES, natively,
for folks who
have built infrastructure
as a service,
it's not a walk in the park.
It's not an easy thing to do.
And what further complicates
is the bigger these cache
databases become, the more
are the failure points,
the higher is the risk matrix.
Currently, we are
facing, on an IES stack,
the bigger disks which are
attached to these cache
databases need encryption,
and these encryption processes
may run for two, three days.
That's our biggest
failure point.
That might hit our SLAs.
So we had been meaning
to get out of IES,
and very recently, as of three
months back, Elastic Cloud,
they announced a [INAUDIBLE]
for HIPAA compliance.
That's excellent.
We need HIPAA for all the
workloads we put on the cloud,
and there's also aggregate
function support.
Where are we on this journey?
We did check out our
application compatibility
on the Elastic Cloud,
Elastic Service.
And we're also looking
into the GCP credits
that we can flow through
the Elastic Cloud instance.
This was an interesting concept.
If you have an Oracle
database, and the ask
is to move away from
Oracle database,
the first thought goes into
finding another database
on the cloud.
So we were no different.
We have an information warehouse
just like many other folks do.
Actually, every shop as
an information warehouse.
So if you reflect upon what was
the reason why that information
warehouse came into
existence, we pretty much
reflected upon
ourselves, and it had
to be a fact-based
quest, because I
report into data and analytics.
So the data has to back
it up for any reasoning.
And we trended each
and every pattern,
what are the workloads running
in the information warehouse?
We came to the conclusion
that there were only
a handful of data analysts
who were using that database
to run queries, and
these are the guys
who were connecting through
Access DB and so on.
So essentially,
what they're doing
is just pulling information
out, and if that's
what they're doing and
not running queries,
why do you need a database?
So when we thought about that
concept, one of our vendors,
Impetus, they have a utility
called Automated Workload
Transformation.
What does the tool do?
You put in different flavors of
software on the left hand side,
and automagically,
on the other side,
a different version comes out.
In our case, we had
PLSQL procedures,
we had C++ applications built
over the last 20 plus years,
and we had OWB, Oracle
Warehouse Builder,
which is also end of
life, Oracle EDL2.
So we push all that application
on the left hand side as input
to the Workload Transformation,
and we [INAUDIBLE] open source
as our model and PaaS.
We wanted it to
be converted into
a Dataproc friendly version.
In our case, we converted
that to [? Deviceproc, ?]
and on that little
black screen, very
hard to interpret, this as
our 14,000 lines of code.
The way the Workload
Transformation works is it
comments the original
application code,
and right underneath, it's going
to put the converted block.
So it's easy to diagnose.
The takeaway would be, just
because you have a database
application, it doesn't
have to be solved
from database to database.
There could be other ways
to solve it without a DB.
We have had different Hadoop
flavors over the years.
I started out with Hortonworks,
before Hortonworks and Cloudera
combined.
But more recently, we shut down
our on prem Cloudera cluster
and removed our workloads
to convert to Dataproc.
And just going into the
weeds here a little bit,
we did work with our internal
cloud team and our network
teams to open up [INAUDIBLE],,
utilized on this [? CP ?]
utility within Hadoop
framework to move data
from HDFS into the
buckets with GCS Buckets.
The nice thing
about Google Cloud
is, by default,
storage is encrypted,
so you cut down that
additional layer.
Saves a lot of time not
having to encrypt again.
The assets that we use,
again, are HIPAA compliant.
For Metastore, we do use
MySQL, a small instance,
and it's dual
replicated for folks
who do not know why Metastore
has been pulled out.
The clusters, as such, are
where this compute is expensive
and storage is cheap
on public cloud.
So the goal should
be to minimize
the utilization of compute.
If you're not using it,
then why is it running 24/7?
That's called transient
cluster, that we destroy it
when they're not being used.
So our Dataproc
clusters that come
into being for one or two
hours, we run the workload,
and then they vanish.
And we do the same
for table structures
and all that good stuff.
It's in the Metastore.
That's what it's doing.
Transiency is super important.
Keep an eye on the cost.
I've been doing cloud
for almost five years
here, so I can
tell the difference
between the old legacy
[? thing ?] of cutting
a big check, and after,
towards the end of five
years lifecycle, your
SLAs start taking a hit.
There's only so much you can do.
You never lose cost because
your hardware can only
support that much.
Your apps might take a hit,
but you're not spending extra.
Whereas on the
cloud, very quickly,
as your workload and
your data increases,
you might be paying
through the nose.
It's imperative, keep your
eyes on the cost optimized.
We ordered our cost
[? chart ?] on a monthly basis,
and also shared our insights
with our senior leadership
on how much are we spending
and what applications
are chewing up that cost.
LOKESH KRIS: That's
great to hear, Anshul.
As you can see,
McKesson addressed
several aspirational goals here.
They wanted to move
into open source option,
and that they wanted to
modernize their analytics,
implement visualization stack,
and more importantly, modernize
a skill set of the organization
and adapt and adopt trends.
Enterprises increasingly
want to adopt open source
and move away from licensed
software wherever possible.
As a business grows,
and more and more data
is made available, and the
need to modernize analytics
[INAUDIBLE] becomes
increasingly important.
Translating this information
into insightful visualizations
becomes a necessity.
Enterprises want to adapt
to meet these modernization
challenges, and it
includes modernizing
the skill set as well.
As enterprises evolve
after adoption,
the focus is on lean DevOps and
control their ongoing spend.
And that was a
wonderful story, Anshul,
and thank you for walking
us through your highly
informative and educative
data modernization journey.
It is especially
interesting to see
how you started this effort
off to integrate siloed
and [INAUDIBLE] within
your organization
with safe methodology,
and address
some very complex challenges
on your replication
and application
databases, your cache
databases, your information
warehouse, and also
the hardware end of life.
These are some of the challenges
that all the enterprises
face today.
Thank you, once again,
and thank you very much.